now this video is long overdue I
apologize for that time to talk about it
but first sponsorship
and before we get started I want to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by Dr Squatch
Squatch continues to change the way men
approach hygiene they're using Nature's
best natural ingredients in their
products none of those harsh chemicals
you can find in some of the other brands
they leave you looking great smelling
great feeling great and because the
holiday season is upon a Santa Jones is
here to give you some stocking stuffer
ideas squash doesn't just have soap
shampoo conditioner deodorant beard oil
let me tell you something about us guys
with beards this is why it's a good gift
idea we all love beard oil we don't
always buy beard oil and the flavor is
crushed Pine which is just liquid
happiness this is all backed by
squatch's 30-day money-back guarantee if
you don't like it if they don't like it
get your money back no questions so
click the link below and use promo code
dsq John's 25 and new customers can get
25 off of your purchase of 40 or more
what happened felt like my hair grew
back and my shirt changed just for 45
seconds so God I wore Ragnarok new God
of War Game the follow-up to the
previous God of War game it's been a few
years for us a few years for the
characters in the game the snow was
rolled in Ragnarok is coming the Norse
gods are very pissed you killed some of
the other Norse gods and because they
announced this is the final God of War
game with Norse mythology and it's
called Ragnarok you know this [ __ ] is
going down before we talk about what I
like about the story I'm gonna talk
about gameplay because it is video game
and gameplay is mostly what you're gonna
be doing and the gameplay was great they
took what worked had some tweaks some
rebalancing in some parts and they send
you forth go forth and prosper pretty
epic action game it's the same world
traversing type formula as seen in the
previous God of Wars open world ish it's
like an open world with guard rails not
talking GTA here more Jedi fall in order
going to different worlds and you're
traversing and then you get abilities
that let you go to new places in those
worlds you see some areas in this game
that you recognize from the previous
game but it looks a bit different also I
appreciate the fact that you don't have
to just reacquire everything thing from
zero I was very pleased with the fact
that you get the blades of chaos right
out the gate in here there is a new
mechanic with the shield though whereas
The Shield felt more like a third weapon
in the previous game it's like they took
the concepts of the big hitting moves
that the shield did in the previous game
they allocated it to different Shields
so rather than having one Shield that
does everything you have to choose how
you're going to use your shield and pick
the shield accordingly but you want the
bigger Shield that's better for blocking
or do you want the high risk High reward
Shield that's better for parrying and
punishing I'm all about that high risk
High reward if I'm blocking with my
shield in a god of war game it's because
I'm trying to get the timing down so I
can counter and punish very few things
in the world gaming or otherwise are as
satisfying as countering an attack in
God of War and punishing accordingly
it's when the enemies of this [ __ ] up
Ragnarok worlds when they realize oh
this is a Souls game and Kratos is the
Soul's boss what do you seem to
understand
I'm not locked in here with you
you're locked in here with me you do
have to unlock special moves and combos
accordingly with your weapons I really
appreciate the fact that every one of
these combos are special moves if you do
it enough times you get an upgrade for
that combo or special move do you want
to do more damage stun what do you want
even when you unlock the move you're
still working on the move I like that
you do get a new weapon in God of War
Ragnarok a spear weapon which I loved
because you have Fire and Ice
respectively the spirit feels more
neutral though it is wind power
technically speaking but it was a great
weapon to go in on one enemy that's also
another thing I loved about the
rebalancing of this game the previous
God of War game I felt like when I got
the blades of chaos it was over it was
Blades of chaos that's what I used I
felt like this game did a better job at
rebalancing the functions of the weapons
Blades of chaos definitely crowd control
I mean yeah if you have an enemy that
has Frost Shields you're gonna use
Blades of chaos no matter what but I
felt like the blaze of chaos were
optimized for hitting a lot of enemies a
lot of crowd control but my weapon for
that need to go in on one single bad
[ __ ] it was the ax or the spear
every weapon gets its play it's not like
when you get a new weapon the previous
weapon is just left out and this is a
very in-depth battle system it's like
any a combination of any two buttons is
going to do something new and I've seen
gameplay footage of people playing this
game online and I'm always met with the
feeling of I don't play like that but
funny enough
it's unlikely I mean there is an
optimized best way to play I'm sure
competitive Gamers already have that
mapped out like they know the frame rate
they know the recovery for each hit I'm
sure there is mathematically an Optimum
way of playing that's just not how I
gain but I found for God of War Ragnarok
this person doesn't play like this
person this person doesn't play like me
I don't play like that person people are
gonna play differently and I'm actually
looking forward to going through this
game again and playing differently you
know turning off certain Combos and
certain moves like okay I'm gonna play
this way now I mean I'm monogamous with
my moves in here are you kidding me when
I find something that works I'm like
that works and I'm gonna do that if I
can't do that move I'm sure I will learn
to make it work and the game is set up
for you to be able to do that very
in-depth battle system I have myself a
good time and now that atreyus is a few
years older he is old enough to have his
own solo missions in which you are
controlling him and now he has a
companion with him as atreus is with
Kratos to help him out I mean that first
happened I was like oh man it never felt
like when most games do that like okay
you're playing as the sub character now
and now they're not as powerful he's not
Kratos by any means no but he does still
kick ass in its own right and the game
isn't divided 50 50. I'm just saying
there are stretches where you do play as
a treas but as what atreus does for the
coming of age angle in this story it's a
coming-of-age story for atreus I've seen
people say oh they nerfed Kratos they
made him it was there is an arc with
Kratos you know he's not the Angry God
killer he used to be I mean look at the
previous game he just wanted to put his
wife's ashes on a mountain and that's it
Gods kept poking and then they poked the
bear enough and well now Kratos is back
there is definitely a difference in the
way he talks with the Trice and this guy
if you look at the previous game he's
like boy quiet in this game he's like
atreus I appreciate you opening up to me
like that if Kratos can be a badass
while simultaneously not being a closed
off dick of War what's wrong with that
it's just gross also so Kratos isn't
badass when the battles are going down
that is on us the gamer that's our
responsibility to make him badass there
now with being Ragnarok and it is all
going down I thought the story was a
compelling one Richard Schiff as Odin
would never have thought he was the one
to be cast as Odin but I really liked
what they were going for with Odin in
here it kind of reminded me of I believe
it was an Alan Watts lecture you know
the plethora of Alan Watts recordings
out there on YouTube or elsewhere I get
my philosophers mixed up sometimes point
is believe it was Alan Watts and I was
listening to this recording of him
talking about how we Mortals human
beings are the end result of Gods like
if there were Gods all seeing
all-knowing Immortal they'd be going
about existence and at a point they'd be
like well this is boring so I'm gonna
Nerf myself you know maybe they don't
know everything all the time now they're
going to be going they're going to be
like well I don't want to just be able
to snap my fingers get anything I want
so I'm going to take that away and
they're going to be going and they're
like well I'm still Immortal and life
doesn't have any flavor to it I still
can't lose life so I'm going to take
that away and in the end what you have
is a human being so if gods are real
they're just going to end up becoming us
eventually also when Troy Achilles has a
great monologue about that the point is
it's like I felt like Odin heard that
and he was like that really speaks to me
because what does a god think when the
buck stops at them and they don't have
anyone to pray to also Ryan Hurst was
greatest Thor everybody it was great I
can't list all the gods but they're
generally speaking voices or actors you
will recognize from game live action
movies TV or otherwise and by the end of
this see this epic I thought it was very
heartfelt satisfying is the word I'm
looking for it's satisfying in gameplay
and satisfying in Story one might call
it a masterpiece is it better than the
first one that's like if the first one
is a 9.8 is this a 9.9 or a 9.7 doesn't
matter what I'm trying to say is God of
War Ragnarok is
awesome tacular
[Music]
I will say for Trophy Hunters out there
the platinum and God of War Ragnarok
easier than the previous God of War game
there is no enemy in this game that's as
difficult as the valkyrie Queen in the
previous game and I will stick to that
to my dying breath everyone who took on
that [ __ ] Valkyrie Queen everyone
just has this phrase
seared into their brain forever and the
phrase is get up brother but God of War
Ragnarok have you played it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]